like the story of father jacob elbow
elba rado an off-duty border patrol
agent who was getting a haircut when his
wife a teacher texted him quote there's
an active shooter help
i love you
he got up from the barber's chair
grabbed the barber shotgun and headed
for the school he entered the building
he began clearing rooms and evacuated
his own daughter and other students here
now for reaction national security
expert aaron cohen along with former d.c
homicide detective and fox news
contributor ted williams uh you know
aaron let me say i think all of us know
even if we're not trained uh the
instinct is we've seen with some of
these parents including the mother that
hopped the fence and ran ran into that
building before it was cleared and
rescued her own two children
that the
law it well the the training is that you
go in and you don't stop until you get
that
shooter what is your take on what you
heard today which clearly is very
concerning i think to a lot of people
well
there's been a very clear active shooter
protocol in place since columbine which
is 30 plus years ago which
essentially led the law enforcement
community to developing
a pretty basic but functional active
shooter response plan which basically
stated that
whoever shows up on the scene tammy
makes entry into the school the law
enforcement officers are armed they're
trained typically to what's
to do what's called forming up into a
diamond formation they can get more than
two or three officers with them at a
time
breach or go into the school and then
begin to head towards the direction of
the fire the sole purpose is to
neutralize the threat right you cannot
put you can't you can't save somebody on
an airplane sitting next to you unless
you put your gas mask or your oxygen
mask on first so that's been in place
for a very long time so clearly the
protocol with this and i want to be
careful
not to not to poo poo all of law
enforcement across the country
because this agency happens to be taking
heat right now i'm very pro-law
enforcement i've been training law
enforcement for almost 20 years
and it just seems that for whatever
reason
this particular agency didn't have the
appropriate protocols in place yeah uh
or didn't have the confidence to be able
to pull off uh making entry with single
two or three uh officers and for
whatever reason the bottleneck in that
hallway uh leads me to believe that they
didn't have the stress training to be
able to engage that shooter and then
froze under duress what i mean by that
is there's a massive chemical dump that
happens we go into tunnel vision we go
into auditory exploration
i understand but that's what training is
for training is to get you used to an
environment so whether it's adrenaline
that gives you amnesia or any other
stress hormones don't drop because
you're whether you're taking a test or
if you're training for an active shooter
you do it over and over in the military
over and over and over again so when
you're really doing it
it's it's you know normal you know ted
you're you're capable of functioning
under that stress i agree with you
that's the point and let me just let me
just say that we all hear um we clearly
don't need to reassert um our support uh
even though we do every day for law
enforcement i am known for this ted you
sir are every one watching this network
but that support ted
works when we because we have standards
and that we we as a result support law
enforcement in the military but it also
has to be that when those standards are
breached that we are free to be able to
note when there is a problem uh i mean
ted i think that this is what what we're
dealing with here it's only we've got to
address what happened here uh because
it's serious and so many people died
you're absolutely right tammy it must be
addressed and i got to tell you where i
would like to start is from the governor
who says that he was misled yet he's not
told us who misled him or he is not no
heads have rolled to this department of
this department of safety
officer who came on the day and said
that it was the wrong decision
where they decided to
hold up and have a barricade
resident to go in
um i think what is needed and necessary
here is an independent investigation you
had 19 angels 19 angels and you had two
teachers to die
as the result of
police officers 19 of them 19 law
enforcement officers sat around
twiddling their fingers instead of going
in and you had brave young girl who was
on the telephone on this 9-1-1 call and
she was trying to get some help she was
saying i need help
there are kids in here and they are live
please send somebody please send
somebody and nothing was happening that
must be investigated tammy yeah you know
and even today aaron at the press
conference there was an fbi
representative there a field agent who
said if we if we find that there's a
federal nexus we will investigate but
clearly
either it's the state or if it's the
federal government which certainly they
don't have a history at this point of
being really
an entity we can trust either but my
goodness something did happen with that
with either leadership or someone else
when you have this magical decision that
no more children are at risk it's now a
different thing that seems
like inexplicable is there any way to
explain that
uh it is inexplicable and and and i
think that the the the the really
important
piece of meat to hang on to here is the
lack of fundamental response again
the the responder has one goal
uh we've been dealing with this in
israel for years it doesn't matter
whether it's a terrorist or whether it's
an active shooter
uh uh
the the motive doesn't matter the action
gets addressed the same way right uh
which is to spot the threat neutralize
the threat and sweep the area and look
for more threats until that entire
school has been swept and even then the
property doesn't get sterilized until a
special entry team goes in and
methodically opens up every closet this
agency knows that there was a major
colossal failure i i think to add to uh
to your other guest's point here i do
think there needs to be an independent
investigation i also think that the
leadership of this police agency should
take the brunt of the responsibility and
step down i think that would be the
right thing to do at this point and
let's get some fresh blood in there and
this is a tactical this is a tactical
situation here which
listen for every second wasted
another innocent person is killed so
that's how long it takes to pull a
trigger you know aaron which means that
these officers need to be flying to the
threat that's it thank you that's your
job you know i i think we're all where
this nation also can learn a great deal
is from israeli police israeli military
the israeli approach in dealing
with dynamics i think could be very
useful but we're going to have to be
looking at this
across the board gentlemen thank you
very much